we've been looking so far at all these
different kinds of wines how they relate
to each other most recently we've been
looking at these guys parallel lines now
you look if you take a pair of parallel
lines let's draw a couple on your page
okay to indicate that these lines are
parallel what did we do
three couple of arrows on like sun that
tells you they're going at the same
direction okay that's great now when
you've got the parallel I said not that
interesting because they didn't have a
touch each other they never a draft but
if we have a way that crosses both of
those which we call it our transversal
okay a line like that you might later
then things start to get interesting
okay now by the way dear member why is
it called a transversal that's a
terrible awkward long name why is it
called a transversal because it's
transversing it's cutting across right
these other two lines so it's literally
the crossing line that's what it means
okay now last time what you had a look
at was corresponding angles
corresponding angles because when you've
got this transversal it cuts across it
makes a whole bunch of new angles here
right just two parallel lines no angles
but wait you've got these transversal
going across you've got a whole bunch in
fact if I'm counting right you've got
one two three four five six seven eight
angles that are formed and they relate
to each other in very very important
ways yes
corresponding wines ankles sorry for you
okay now this is what you looked at last
time okay so for instance if I call this
angle actually let's up let's put some
labels on this dictionary because you
guys know how to talk about angles you
know how to describe them and name them
so let's call this line a B let's call
this one C D and a log here we'll call
this P Q is s for not not okay now if
for instance I wanted to talk about this
angle here right that angle right up in
there how would we name it there's a few
different ways that are all valid okay
could someone give me one suggestion
yeah angle Hur okay sir
remember you have your angle symbol
there which literally it looks like an
angle okay angle a QR that's perfect I
think because aq is one of the arms cute
ours the other arm and Q that point in
the middle
what's that this especially great now
this angle here we say it corresponds to
another one of those eight angles that
are on it now that we've labeled this
thing can you see which angle does it
correspond to can we name it
okay now you can't say ah but there's a
problem with that isn't there cuz ah it
could be a whole bunch of angles right
there's one two three four angles that
are all at us so we need to be a little
more specific great see our yes okay so
these two angles right now these two it
was here are corresponding angles you
can see the disabilities so this is
revision right because they're
corresponding angles we can say that
they're equal to each other
do you remember this knots learning if
you're everybody yes okay good now the
reason for this you can't just say are
they're equal because cuz I want them to
be okay you have to provide
justification a reason for why that's
true okay so on the side here you want
to provide the reason you would say
corresponding angles now you got to I
see you can either say on parallel lines
bless you on parallel lines are equal
but I like to put a little more detail
man okay and it's actually a little bit
shorter to say I'm not just gonna say
parallel lines I'm gonna say which
parallel lines I have right which of the
lines are parallel a B and C D right sir
to say that to write down it they're
parallel I can say corresponding angles
oh now do you remember what's the symbol
that we have for parallel lines it's
literally just a pair of parallel lines
that's convenient isn't it okay chorus
20 and goes on a B which is parallel to
CD they're equal
okay so see these two lines either of
them are fine I think this is a bit
nicely because it gives you a little
more detail even though I don't have
them right now if I had more parallel
lines going all over the place it might
be confusing which ones are you talking
about right so this actually gives you a
bit more detail and if you have a look
at it it's actually a bit shorter too
right so this is kind of a this is okay
but I like this even better okay so
there you go yeah totally I it's really
good when laziness equals more detail
that's that's a we usually see the way
around but anyway okay now just before
we move off that there's a lot of other
corresponding angles too right for
instance if we went P Q B if I caught it
this angle up here put the top on it hey
P Q B what would be the angle
corresponding to P B have a look at it
could someone give me a hand up and tell
me which
s T okay now it had to be this angle in
heels right now be careful because this
is tricky it's really hard to it because
it's surfing angles here right
is it corresponding okay now I don't
think it is and he's how I know his
never second is right I like to look at
this angle P Q B right and which way is
it facing okay maybe the way I've drawn
it's kind of facing up yes
now corresponding one of the synonyms
for corresponding is matching right so
in other words these angles are doing
the same thing right so this guy is kind
of facing up that way right I want to
look for another angle that's facing in
the same direction right which to me is
very close to SRD but I think it's on
the other side because this guy's going
off on that direction see how they sort
of look so cute ah deep this angle here
okay now let's just test it now it
doesn't actually check it out what
direction is it facing what's going that
way and that does look like it's
matching together okay now please don't
miss that it's really tricky identify a
device that's why wait - well I got it
now so these are the kinds of shapes
you've got P Q B is equal to what we say
q D for the same reason for the same
reason so when you've got corresponding
angles the kind of shape that gets
formed have a look at it here if I have
a look at that first pair it looks like
this and they're facing down that way
can you see that and these are the two
angles I was interested in if you have a
look at these other two kind of looks
like this and these were the two angles
I was interested in can you see that
so this is the kind of shape that we've
got right if you turn it around it kind
of looks like yeah you see that looks
like an F and that's how you can see
which one's a car spun into each other
okay now corresponding angles they're
not the only interesting ones so this is
this other name that I was eliminating
before alternate angles okay now here's
his the angle I'm interested in let's
start back at hur again okay now I'm
trying to work out what's the
relationship between a QR and this cute
ID we were talking about that down here
whoa so I've got this angle and I've got
this angle that's not try to work out
the relationship so there's more
relationships here that I can take a bit
more paths for instance a few lessons
back down I think we were up enough
80234 memory
we gave a QR and eqb we gave those two
angles and named they have a
relationship to each other
do you remember what they're called
least then not adjacent because they're
not next to each other is a phrase
actually you know yeah well done did you
hear that that's right so have a look at
these two guys right these are
vertically opposite now would be
revision3 Shirley covered sir Shh let's
write this down
okay go a QR is equal to angle PQ b
because because they're vertically
opposite angles
okay now by the way see how I'm taking
the time to write all this on the right
hand side I know it takes a long time
but this is to be honest kind of the
important part because all of this it's
like it's all just letters but this is
now why why is there a relationship this
is the power you show that you
understand what's going on okay so even
though it takes a long time it's right
this is the important part
besides equal okay but but but hold on a
second PQ b you say go up here right you
told me like five minutes ago
you told me that that angle is equal to
Q ID didn't you what was the reason why
this one and this one yeah these to a
corresponding I think in fact I've got
it written there I just forgot to write
the reason okay so if PQ B&Q idea the
same I can just swap them out I can say
this
can you see what I've done right
this is equal to this angle but I know
this is angle is equal to this one so
I've swapped it out it's a bit more
swapping so what's that look like that
means that I could actually get rid of
this guy up here and I can only be
interested in these two and they're
equal
right but they're not corresponding are
they what do you say put it back on
later sure woman okay yes
yes that's right so we're sort of taking
two steps to get there but be careful
when you talk about angles you've got a
name all three of the points right angle
a it's like well at least in this
diagram it's not a man-girl angle there
but I can't just say hey look you
because I don't know which angle Q it is
right there's four of them
so what are we got here and a QR angle
QR d they're equal but they're not
correspond because look at them they're
facing in opposite directions I think
this one's going down that way and it
was this way so they're not
corresponding but it's still equal now
since they're facing opposite directions
that's why we call alternate angles okay
alternate English okay now we're showing
a great question just now which was do
these two be alternate angles do they
have to be on opposite sides of the
transversal and the answer is yes in
fact that's so it's such a guess that I
think it's worth writing down underneath
where you've said alternate angles in
some ways that's one of the big
differences between corresponding angles
and also the ones see corresponding
angles they're all in the same sign
right there matching on the same side of
the transversal the alternate ones are
on opposite sides of the transversal
okay so for instance let me get another
color and this will help if you have
another color too that'll be great for
instance we can see more alternate
angles here can't we for instance be
cute ah let me put a um
it'll help joint out because otherwise
it's really hard to talk about what's
going on which angle is alternative to a
group a queue
ah well it's gotta be on the opposite
side a transversal right so not on this
side it's gonna be over this side okay
so it looks to me like it's going to be
over yeah can you see that
so BGR is alternate to qrc thank you see
and I can say that directly I can say
angle B Q is equal to angle Q ah see why
very similar to this light here
alternate angles on a be parallel to CD
very cool okay so I'm going to start a
little pause for a little while because
you've been listening to me for a long
time and it says to a in your textbook
starts talking about these alternate
angles there is a third kind that we're
going to get to by the end of the lesson
but I don't want you to just sit there
and absorb stuff from me for so long so
I'm going to stop talking for a little
while okay do leave some space for the
third type of angle I'm going to tell
you about right and we'll do some
diagrams as well but this is altered
angles now you remember I said look
corresponding it was they look like an F
you see that there they are
what do alternate angles look like if
you just took the alternate angles well
I think they look like for example look
at this one here
it looked like this look like that
didn't it yeah and then if I have a look
at the other side I
right and I've got this shape over here
I think that looks like it said
sometimes backwards but that's the kind
of shape with me so there's an F there's
a said that that kind of shape is
important it helps you to recognize
where the alternate angles are